so our first question for ewan is going
to come from david from extra go for it
david
hi david
hello you and congratulations thank you
i listened to your acceptance speech and
i was struck
i thought if i if i read this correctly
it seemed quite emotional for you
this um towards the end it seemed like
when you're
you know saying hello to your girls and
uh it seems like this had a great great
significance for you can you sum up what
it means to you to win this award
yeah it was it was um
well it was a surprise it was a surprise
and i it's incredibly nerve-wracking
sitting there waiting to be
for you and the category to come up and
there's so many people you want to thank
and write rightly you want to thank and
then the fear that you might forget them
or
um
but yeah my kids were texting me my
daughters were texting me
we're on this group chat and they're
they're all in different place you know
three my kids are on the east coast my
eldest clara is 25 she lives in new york
my
19 year old esther is at college in new
york my 20 year old jamian is at college
in connecticut
my little nooks watching at home in um
in la
and um
my son is only you know 12 weeks old so
he's not watching this at all but they
were very in my mind and they were
texting and this group chat before i
went up you know before my
category came up and they're like i
can't find it they're like it's on cbs
and like i'm watching on this and good
luck dad and it was uh they were very
present in my mind and um yeah there's
just a lot of um
beautiful things said tonight in some of
the other acceptance speeches and you
know i have four daughters and the
importance of
uh
women and women's rights and equality
for women and equal pay for women it's
like
it's so great to be in a room where
people are talking about that and
um i always think about my girls and and
so that that is uh moving and important
wonderful congratulations thanks mate
thank you sir yeah
thank you david next up we have kate
from access hollywood go okay
you and congratulations for your win on
this i loved your sweet shout out to
mary and little lori i'm just curious is
this what your date nights look like for
uh mom and dad most most every night
yeah this is kind of what we're up to at
the moment yeah
no it was very weird to leave the house
without him tonight it was very strange
um the feeling to to be it's the first
time we've ever gone out anywhere
without him so um
yeah it was odd but it'd be nice to go
back home
can you tease any obi-wan for us
not really we finished our shooting our
series
and it was really really good fun i
really enjoyed working with debra chow
and um
the you know i think it will not
i think it will not disappoint i mean
you know
i think it's going to be good i'm i i
had a really good time making it and
worked with some really wonderful people
uh lovely people and
uh
the new track the new technology that we
employed doing it is cool and it was a
different experience than making the
original three films that i did and i i
really really liked it it was good
but i'm not going to tell you anything
else thank you
thank you so much